thank you
well this month is autoimmune Awareness
Month autoimmune disease is when the
body's natural defense system can't tell
the difference between healthy cells and
foreign cells and attacks the healthy
tissue by mistake some examples are type
1 diabetes and some some thyroid
disorders Laura negretti is live in the
studio sharing doctors advice for
treatment good morning Lauren Good
morning Sherry while those doctors at
UMC say to keep up with your annual
checkups since it's important to create
a plan of care with your primary care
providers identifying the disease on
time means a better outcome a doctor
there says thyroid disorders can be
treated on time with thyroid replacement
therapy type 1 diabetics will always
need insulin and The dietitian at UMC
meantime says there are things you can
do from a lifestyle and diet perspective
to help minimize the amount of meds or
disorder impacts
with Hashimoto's is that we have found a
link between gluten and improving your
Hashimoto's symptoms so reducing gluten
in your diet can sometimes be beneficial
some people see a benefit some people
don't so there is that connection with
other autoimmune disorders and the
gluten Factor
she said when you're serving yourself
look at your plate half it half should
be non-starchy veggies the other half
divided by between proteins and Grains
you could actually measure your portion
sizes with your hand the Palm is about
the size of three ounces of meat as your
protein and your hands cupped like this
could be about one cup so your rice easy
tip back to you guys